in this video I'm going to condense my
five years of copyrighting wisdom into
just five minutes by using 21 rapid fire
lessons that I wish I would have known
before becoming a professional
copywriter let's Dive Right In lesson
number one the number one metric to
measuring great copy is sales if it
doesn't sell it's not great copy doesn't
matter how good it sounds how easy it
flows how much you like your headline if
it doesn't sell it's not great copy
lesson number two the most profitable
niches of copywriting in our generation
is emails social media ads and landing
pages I would avoid social media organic
content blog writing anything that's not
directly attached to selling a customer
again number one metric is sales lesson
number three a deadline is the number
one way to get people to take action by
Nature humans are lazy they don't want
to take action unless they have to a
deadline tells them they have to lesson
number four Vision sells Logistics does
it most people talk about the features
of their product it does this it does
that but at the end of the day people
want to see themselves using your
product or the transformation from your
product paint a vision of what the
future looks like after using your
product lesson number five use bigger
proof not a bigger promise a bigger
promise creates skepticism in people
they're already skeptical whether you're
you're going to deliver or not bigger
proof more testimonials more case
studies tells people that this actually
works it increases believability and
they trust you lesson number six tell
the reason why you're selling it can't
just be to make money off of them people
don't want to hear that they want to
hear a bigger Mission as to why you are
selling and it'll make it more
believable to buy from you lesson number
seven is right with a timer I use the
3333 Eugene shorts method where I have a
timer on my desk I set it for 33 minutes
33 seconds I click Start and I don't
stop writing copy until that timer goes
off I do this three to four times a day
which usually ends up about 2 hours of
writing and I outright everyone I Know
lesson number eight fear is a bigger
motivator than desire people fear
missing out more than actually gaining
something else so tell them what they
will miss out by not buying your product
lesson number nine benefit plus proof is
still the best headline formula I've
ever used for example don't say new
memory foam technology pillow say wake
up without neck pain tried and approved
by 15,000 customers get it wake up
without neck pain is the benefit proof
is the Tried by 15,000 customers do that
for any headline if you're not sure what
to write and you will smash lesson
number 10 people don't care about your
product they care about their problem
stop trying to find customers for the
stuff you sell start trying to find
stuff you sell for customers lesson
number 11 you cannot create desire you
have to find what people already want
and then Channel their current desire
into a product that gives them what they
want lesson number 12 spend 80% of your
time researching the market you are
riding for people don't have writers
block or write bad copy they just
haven't researched the market enough to
know what those people care about or
what you should talk about increase your
research time lesson number 13 sell bu
repel give people reasons not to buy
your stuff exclude who this content or
product is not for people want what they
can't have and so when you make your
product something they can't or
shouldn't have they want it even more
lesson number 14 obey the 40 4020 rule
40% of your sales is the quality of your
list the other 40% of your sales is how
good your offer is and the last 20% is
how good your copy is if you have a
crappy list and a crappy offer it
doesn't matter how good your copy is do
not write a single word until you've
nailed down your target audience and
nail down an irresistible offer lesson
number 15 a great product is better than
great copy it is really hard to write
great copy and sell a crummy product
with a great product the copy
practically writes itself and it takes
the same amount of time to write for a
bad product as it does for a good
product so you might as well write for a
good one lesson number 16 you don't have
to be a great writer you have to be a
great rewriter editing is the magic
behind great copy John Carlton once
rewrote a salesletter 21 times before it
actually took off in the market do not
be afraid to Perfection your writing
lesson number seven 17 specificity cells
don't say quick dry shaving cream say
shaving cream that dries in 60 seconds
don't say lose weight fast say lose 10
lb in 10 days lesson number 18 write at
a fifth grade level most people think
and write simply so you have to unlearn
all that garbage that you learn in
school about pros and flows and
paragraphs that stuff's great for poetry
but horrible for copyrighting lesson
number 19 swim in a smaller Pond 25
years ago when Brooks running shoes was
competing with Nike they were trying to
compete by being an all athletic brand
but when they Niche down to just being
running shoes for runners they became a
billion dooll brand so instead of being
a small fish in a big pond you need to
be a big fish in a small pond you'll be
able to charge more sell more know your
Market better and be a better copywriter
lesson number 20 tell stories people
remember remember stories up to 22 times
as much as facts and when you
incorporate stories into your
copyrighting people get addicted and
they're likely to read the whole thing
which means they are way more likely to
buy from you and the last lesson lesson
21 do not major in the minors we live in
the most distracted economy of all time
we have opportunity fatigue we could do
this we could do that we can write here
we can right there I want you to pick
one market pick one product and write
great copy for that you repeat that
system for years and years to come you
will be rich I promise you everything
else is a distraction get focused One
Market one product one great piece of
copy I hope this encouraged you today I
hope it was jam-packed full of value and
if you enjoyed it then you're really
really going to like my free
copyrighting guide copyrighting Catalyst
which actually has 63 cash cow
copyrighting tips for you to eat by size
lessons just like this one juice up your
copyrighting game and put a lot more
cash in your pockets I hope that's
helpful if you want copyrighting
Catalyst hit the link in the description
below whoa oh technical error okay so
I'm editing this video and I just
realized that the end of the video come
up I just told you to put a link in the
description below and then after that
nothing happened then my video
completely cut off apparently my camera
shut off or whatever so I'm going to
wrap this up just like this while I'm
editing go go ahead if you want
copyright and Catalyst hit the link in
the description below to go ahead and
grab it also please do not forget to
like And subscribe to the channel I put
in a ton of hard work uh for you to
enjoy everything so I appreciate you
thank you so much uh sorry for the weird
ending but now you get a little behind
the scenes thank you like And subscribe
I'll chat with you soon